opération nettoyage de la décharge
sauvage de carrières sous poissy une
première phase lancée au mois de janvier
2020 avec déjà 65 % de la masse
collecter spécialisée dans le recyclage
des matériaux l'entreprise biche et à
filiale du groupe colas est chargé de
trier et valoriser les déchets notamment
avec cette plateforme de tri dans la
plaine on va effectuer un premier tri ce
qui va nous permettre de séparer les
gros éléments
donc tout ce qui est là qui va pas
pouvoir être valorisé la partie 30,80
donc c'est ce tapis là sur lesquels on a
installé un aspirateur donc qui va
aspirer les éléments légers ensuite le
reste passe sur le tapis centrale tente
dans le band tri donc à l'intérieur de
la cabine ya un tapis principal quatre
personnes qui sont chante deux et deux
de chaque côté et qui vont trier le
département a sélectionné trois
entreprises dans le cadre de cette
opération avec une mission de
surveillance et de pose de clôture pour
protéger cet espace un investissement
d'1 5 million d'euros de l'état et du
conseil départemental
vous avez là la démonstration que quand
la ja coordination née volonté de la
part des acteurs publics lorsqu'ils s'y
mettait les moyens barre il arrive à des
résultats spectaculaires
nous voulions voir le résultat du
travail collectif de divers acteurs
publics et privés jeu par les
entreprises et les acteurs publics ses
pensées départementale communauté
urbaine l'epamsa qui est un
établissement public de l'état je le
rappelle
et l'état dans ce travers le président a
prononcé le chiffre de huit cent mille
euros que nous devons l'engagement du
préfet de région ile de france
une deuxième phase de nettoyage va être
lancée au mois d'août 2020 objectif
dépolluer 75% de la plaine de déchets
d'ici à la fin de l'année un projet
d'aménagement d'un espace naturel
protégé en cours de réflexion est prévu
une fois la dépollution terminée